we do believe that there is a linked
criminality and specific Doug rich he
basically had her entire face in his
jaws there will be a variety of reasons
why God will bite man often it will be
something that man has done that's the
address scenario view of it a full
systematic search of the venue will be
conducted by Barrett offices over the
past year I've been given unprecedented
access to the Met status dogs unis don't
worry if you've never heard of them not
many people have there a team of
specialists offices and their job is to
protect us from dangerous dogs to
conduct systematic search of any and
sees anything loose dogs we're at a
briefing in North London
a local man Daniel Howard has been
threatening officers with his dogs
some are thought to be pit bull terriers
a banned breed
there's section 1 dogs there and there's
good evidence that they are his dogs and
that is an offense and he could be
arrested for that this is one of the
dogs they're worried about a Turkish
Kangol she'll bring a Powell we are
prepared to deal hopefully with just
about everything the advantage of the
dog captured powers option we would loop
that around the dog's head secure the
dog in that way and also we can control
where the dog is we also have as another
bit of kit an animal control shield it's
an electric shield a lot of this kit a
it works and it is very effective but
one of the biggest things it does quite
frankly is encourages owners to behave
and do what they we need them to do if
the dog does bite someone will get a
hold on the dog and then will get it off
this is one of the SD use biggest
operations backed up by the tactical
support group and local police nearly 50
officers will be involved we've seized
more dogs than this but dogs with
clearly to criminality and the number of
addresses just makes it complicated
the challenge for sergeant Peter Madden
is to find the dogs before their suspect
is tipped on the nature of this type of
job is that actually something might
change and we might need to make some
fairly quick and rapid operational
decisions I wouldn't be at all surprised
if we ended up having a - one address to
another if intelligence suggests we need
to be elsewhere
a team arrives at one of the addresses
there's nothing here but news comes in
states do not six don't to the other
address thank you
I like the place coming over the Dale I
like that
okay secure the box Bobby please okay
they're all securing the garden
pit bull here on the chair
stairs
with them
the main subject came out and got a bit
agitated you've got to be quick if
you're if you're behind the curve if
you're too slow all of a sudden you've
got a nightmare and if you don't get
control of the dog quickly when you've
got an opportunity to then potentially
the dog joins in gets excited starts
biting people and you're in difficult
positions the Intel suggested the dog
didn't go out very often it says bat
claws are very long don't doesn't get
taken out the Kangol is in the garden as
well as anything else you can see that
this dog is desperately emaciated
it's got no ears and whether that's been
cut off to make it look harder I don't
know but this is a very very skinny dog
purely and simply because it's not been
fed enough or it's got a medical issue
that they haven't treated over the years
we've heard lots of reports when we're
going on raids of dogs that are trained
to attack on a word of command that's
rarely the case very very rarely our own
police dogs are trained in bite work but
they're not aggressive in the normal
course of events this dog when we came
down here was absolutely fine towards us
it was growling and telling us to go
away because we're invading its space
and we just gave it a bit of time made
friends with it and the dogs good as
gold with us now and that's what that's
our preferred option and that's normally
the case more often than not
sergeant madam will learn later
he's got feeling about the Kangol
spotter in total 13 dogs have been
seized from this morning's raid not all
a ban breeds the SD you must decide
which ones are
confiscated animals are held at police
contracted kennels
while their fate is this for the dogs
that end up in these kennels because of
welfare issues it's the best thing that
could happen to them there's expert
veterinary care there's regular exercise
food and water and they're probably
given more attention than they've ever
received in their lives but for bond
breeds like this Pit Bull Terrier puppy
being here is the canine equivalent of
death row identifying the dogs is
convoluted pitbulls are essentially
mongrels so there are no breed specifics
almost half the dogs are suspected to be
banned breeds and that's part of the
assessment today but also as the part of
the assessment we're looking at whether
or not there are any welfare issues with
the dogs or unless there's a medical
problem with the dog there's no way a
dog should be in the condition such as
this at this age inspected Jan ekeus
thinks one of the dogs is another banned
breed one rarely seen in this country a
dog o Argentino I suspect this probably
come in as a very small puppy so it'd
have been difficult to tell what it was
at that age it's all that come in from
North America where it's coming from
Europe probably as a profit-making
venture Daniel Howard's Instagram post
confirms the suspicions seized dogs that
can't be returned to their owners or
rehomed or destroyed that's why the
Dangerous Dogs Act is so controversial
so occasionally she can have Carol
Eden's world fell apart when she had her
puppy fudge taken away from her my
officers from Merseyside Police she says
without warning and without
justification I had the banging on the
door and because I live on my own I was
a bit what's that at this hour of the
night it was 10 o'clock at night there
was just lots of police cars outside
police women said to me we've got reason
to believe you've got a pitbull - which
I actually went to pitbull I've got a
stuffy and she said can we come in and
see and I said yeah not a problem
she said I just need you to sign this
and then we can get out of your way and
I said what is it I need to go in and
get me glasses I wouldn't be able to
read it and she said oh it's fine she
said it's just to say that you never
been kissed by us in any way whatsoever
I took her out took her up to the van
she thought she was going for a walk and
two policemen got hold of a back end
pushed her in the back of the round
should the jaws and drove off and that
was the last year of us all it's the
last day of the service
an hour later I got a phone call from
the vets to say and that you don't have
been put down I was devastated honestly
even now the guilt is hard it really is
hard hard that she has a chance I could
have fought for her I just hope that she
wasn't too scared that she wasn't in
this strange building getting the need
to put in a leg which is basically what
they did and then taking her last breath
with strangers I just think it was so
cruel fudge was put to sleep five years
ago since then the DDA has been amended
but it still breeds specific and dogs
are still being destroyed
sergeant Madden has served 20 years as a
police dog handler I've seen him around
dogs a lot sometimes he's firm and I
suppose he has to be but mostly he's
kind and affectionate I want to know how
he squares that with putting down cease
dogs
I take no satisfaction in in destroying
any healthy animal but often we will
have no legal options available to us
but not all the dogs that we that come
through us are suitable to be rehomed
some because of what they have done if
they've bitten someone and others
because of the law and many of them will
be abandoned with us by their owners
sergeant Madden's hunch about a cache
the Kangol is right he's very sick
he might you're not feeling very well
are you the heart has an abnormal beat
to it he also has fluid on his chest and
in his abdomen with this sort of
addition unfortunately I mean he
couldn't collapse into unconsciousness
and never wake up again
the SDU has joined Trident specialists
met unit at tackles gang violence
pitbulls became popular after a
crackdown on knives and guns there's
less risk being caught with a dog and
it's also why they're known as weapon
dogs status tops one of the requirements
for any registered fans brains almost
all of its pitbulls is that the dog is
insured and they can get their insureds
for a couple of advisors and it has to
has to be renewed each year the dog the
owner here has got a copy of their
insurance so that all is good if you
have an address that the people that
were here moved to the registered owner
the dog was murdered the dog is still
registered at this address and there was
no insurance for the dog it's the place
we're going to see the dog take the dogs
today or speak to your brother in due
course and if he's got insurance
fine you know that that's okay dogs as
you can say good as coal they will go
off at the kennels we'll make some
inquiries with the registered owner and
see if he has got insurance and we'll
take it from there
the SDU was set up in 2009 they're just
as busy today dog attacks are rising and
that that that's borne out by facts and
figures since the legislation change in
May 2014 it was difficult to say what
was happening because we were reporting
more offenses than ever before
due to the private police an amendment
an extension haven't compared the
figures for the first six months of last
year and the first six months of this
year certainly in the Met we're seeing
another 7% increase in seizures this
year than we did last there's a good
reason inspector ohhara is so committed
to removing potentially dangerous dogs
from our streets the side of her face
had been opened up it was just
horrendous
Carla and her brother Luka were excited
about Christmas they were on their way
home from a fair - Unleashed Pit Bull
Terriers were walking towards I just
heard the scream I just heard the mum
and I obviously instantly turned around
instantly ran back you know the
adrenaline just kicked in at that point
and as I turned back and ran the few
steps back towards him I basically I saw
Carla on the ground with the dog I just
did what a man would do I instinctively
started yelling screaming and left on to
them on to the dog on to them and I
basically had to prise the jaws of this
dog off Carla's place he was he
basically had her entire she was four so
she was very little and her entire face
in his jaws
dooshka flagged down a car and asked the
driver to rush her to a nearby hospital
I got home to a empty house
made a few calls couldn't contact disco
then I get a call this is the were all
free or thought has been attacked by a
dog get here as quickly as you can so I
literally just leg it down the road as
fast as I can
walked in see - go first and in bits
apologizing obviously I had the motherly
guilts of I didn't look after our
children well enough and I let this
happen
that was the major emotion that was
going through me oh my god I can't
believe I've done this I can't believe
this has happened to my daughter
yeah and actually why yes dooshka saved
Carla's life essentially
had the dog gone a little bit deeper
here kind of the jugular area I mean it
did it definitely it cut the hole of
this bottom part of habits that I
severed all of the muscles across the
bottom there and which isn't far away
from jugular it fractured her cheekbone
could have easily crushed her skull in
his jaws she had cuts all the way around
her eye as well I mean it it's it's a
miracle I'm absolutely sure did not lose
that high unbelievable and there was a
lot of a lot of references there
life-changing injuries life-changing
injuries and I remember just grabbing
one of the doctors and saying what do
you mean life-changing injuries I just
didn't want to hear it I think I didn't
want to hear those words life-changing
injuries what an amazing girl
it was unbelievably strong girl you know
I they took the bandages off the nurses
saw my face and they said you need to
sit down because it was inside of her
face had been opened up it was just
horrendous
and you know they put it back on and at
that point I thought my god she is so
brave the Cutler's credit the medical
team on duty at the hospital that night
and the following weeks and months for
rebuilding Carla's face and her hopes
for the future we had the amazing
amazing look that I think the top
plastic surgery consultant in the Royal
Free happens to be on duty that day he
basically said I've just come on call
I've just heard what happened I have a
list of operations today as long as my
arm but Carla's gonna be the first thing
and I have extensive experience in nerve
repair and facial reconstruction that
was an incredible stroke of luck she's
got a metal plate in her face
where a tooth bone was fractured so she
had to have MRI scan to just make sure
the integrity of her skull was okay and
whether they could go with that and
whether they did you know how they would
shape the metal plate
and that was a long operation yeah five
days six days we were able to come home
with a lot of antibiotics medication you
know bags yeah bags and bags of
medication and we had to go back a few
days later the stitches was so so so so
many hundreds of stitches she's small
she's growing nerve repair takes up to
two years and even at that point you
know after two years we'll see where we
are you know whether there will be
further discussions at that point we
don't know barely coping with the trauma
of the attack Cutler's were about to
learn some confusing and heartbreaking
news the dog that attacked Carla was
known to the police was under
investigation
had killed the cat and attacked the
cat's owner only three months previous
for this and basically it was a
confession that a mistake had been made
and that the correct procedures hadn't
been followed and therefore that dog
should never have been on the street in
December on December the 4th when Carla
was attacked that dog should have been
taken away from its owner and dealt with
legally way before that the police knew
all this this was all reported and it
wasn't there wasn't follow though it
wasn't followed up the breed of the dog
wasn't checked they took the owners word
that it was a staff II wasn't and that
was incredibly incredibly hard to hear
why was that mistake made who made the
mistake what was ultimately Carla paid
the price the two officers who failed to
seize the dog before it savaged Carla
and the supervisor were investigated in
turn
there's no doubt in my mind whatsoever
that there was a missed opportunity for
an earlier intervention to get hold of
that dog and take it off the streets and
at least put it in a place where it was
secure and safe to be and that would
have prevented the incident that
happened to Karla and that is I have to
say most regrettable that that wasn't
taken what I can say is that the advice
that was available to the officers at
the time was not as strong as it could
have been the owner was sent to prison
for two years his dog was destroyed the
Dangerous Dogs Act was supposed to
protect children like Karla I wanted to
know if inspector ohhara thought it had
achieved its aim it's difficult to
measure whether it's been an effective
piece of legislation because you can
never measure the preventative effect
that it has had you will never know how
many dogs there would have been on the
streets of this particular type for
example if the legislation hadn't been
introduced but I think by and large it's
it is fit for purpose and it could be
enhanced with a few small tweaks in the
end I suppose inspector O'Hara is right
we can't ever know how many lives have
been saved or attacks prevented by the
DDA we would put to sleep probably
around 300 dogs this year no I have to
sort of draw the inference here that
they're not necessarily all healthy dogs
or safe dogs to have our own people far
from it in fact and what I can say is we
have rehomed around 56 dogs this year so
far and we won't destroy a dog without
some kind of a paper trail so a
disclaimer when the dog can't lawfully
be rehomed a court order that says it
must be destroyed but if a court rules
that a dog is not a danger to public
safety and the owner is a fit and proper
person then nine times out of ten that
dog will go on
Daniel Howard has begun a six-month jail
term after he pleaded guilty to 17
offences eight of his dogs have been
destroyed
this one has been rehomed
akaash became a firm favorite with
kennel staff but never recovered and had
to be put down
after more than 38 years service
sergeant Peter Madden has retired from
the force for a civilian job he's still
working with dogs there will be a
variety of reasons why dog will bite man
often it will be something that man has
done dogs are man's best friend I would
question whether man is dog's best
friend the attack on Carla happened two
years ago duster and Tony have only
spoken now in the hope that what
happened then to their little girl will
never happen to another child again
Lucas still crosses the road whenever he
sees a dog but the trauma of witnessing
the attack and his little sister is
fading carla continues to astound her
parents and everybody else with her
courage what if her friends asked me the
other day you know when's Carles car
gonna go you know just as a aside and
it's like well you know what it's never
gonna go you know people especially
still I've always have a scarf but it
will fade and it will fade more and more
she's rebuilding her young life smile my
beautiful smile